ya estamos muy listos para resolver este
sistema que obtuvimos en el vídeo
anterior y vamos a resolverlo para
nuestras variables desconocidas a b y c
muy bien entonces lo que vamos a hacer
en este vídeo es vamos a tratar de
resolverlo de la siguiente forma vamos a
tomar esta primera ecuación y vamos a
digamos vamos a relacionarla con esta de
acá para obtener una ecuación solo en
las variables a y b es decir vamos a
tratar de de cancelar la variable c y
eso lo podemos hacer si por ejemplo
tomamos esta primera esta primera
ecuación la azul la ponemos tenemos 8 a
8 a + 4 b + 2 se igual a 5 y luego vamos
a multiplicar la ecuación verde por
menos 2 y después la sumamos si
multiplicamos la primera por menos 2 nos
queda menos 2 a menos 2 b menos 12
igual a menos 2 muy bien entonces si
sumamos estas dos ecuaciones lo que
obtenemos son 8 a menos 2 a éstos son 6
a y luego 4 b menos 2 veces son 2 b y lo
bonito de haber hecho esto es que estas
dos se cancelan y ya no aparece la
variable c y esto deberá ser igual a 5
menos 2 que es 3 muy bien entonces
obtenemos una ecuación en las variables
a y b si queremos resolver para a y b
necesitamos otra ecuación como lo
obtenemos pues de relacionar esta con la
ahora la 'roja' que vamos a hacer
exactamente lo mismo tenemos 27 27
+ 9 + 3 c igual a 14 y luego para
cancelar las sedes necesitamos
multiplicar la ecuación verde por menos
3 x menos 3 entonces tendremos menos
tres a menos tres b menos tres se iguala
menos tres por uno que es menos tres y
volvemos a sumar volvemos a sumar y que
es lo que obtenemos tenemos 27 menos
tres son 24 a 9 menos 3 son 6 b y estos
se cancelan y ahora tenemos 14 menos 3
son 11 muy bien entonces ya lo que lo
que obtuvimos son dos ecuaciones con dos
variables con a y b así que ahora
necesitamos cancelar algunas de ellas
para obtener la red el valor de la otra
variable entonces por ejemplo si
nosotros multiplicamos esta ecuación de
aquí por menos que será por menos 3
vamos a poder cancelar las veces vamos a
ver esto menos 3 por 6 son
- 18
-18 a lo voy a poner mejor con otro
color
quizás con amarillo entonces tenemos
menos 18 a menos tres por dos veces son
menos seis y menos tres por tres es
menos nueve así que ahora si sumamos
tenemos 24 a menos 18 a son 6
y 6 b menos seis vea kilogramos que se
cancelarán así que esto nos queda 11
menos nueve es 2 y esto ya es muy
sencillo de resolver tendremos seis a
seis a igualados entonces podemos pasar
dividiendo o dividimos de ambos lados
entre seis y tenemos a igual a dos entre
seis que esto es exactamente un tercio
así que ya tenemos el valor de a ahora
basta sustituirlo en esta ecuación para
obtener por ejemplo el valor de ve muy
bien entonces qué es lo que tenemos
tenemos
por el valor de a que es un tercio por
un tercio más
2 b 2 b igual a 3 entonces 6 por un
tercio o lo que es lo mismo 6 entre 3 es
2 más 2 b esto es igual a 3 si restamos
de ambos lados
si restamos 2 de ambos lados tenemos 2 b
igual a 1 muy bien y si dividimos entre
2 de ambos lados tenemos b igual a un
medio entonces ya tenemos el valor de a
ya tenemos el valor de b ahora ya
podemos obtener el valor de c
simplemente hay que sustituirlo aquí por
ejemplo si sustituimos aquí tendríamos a
valía un tercio entonces tenemos un
tercio más el valor de b que vale un
medio más
sé que es lo que queremos saber debe ser
igual a 1 así que vamos a pasarlo todo a
sextos que es un común denominador
entonces por ejemplo un tercio cuántos
sextos son pues son dos sextos un medio
son tres sextos más c igual a uno que
son seis sextos muy bien entonces de
esto de aquí tenemos cinco sextos más c
igual a seis sextos y finalmente si
restamos cinco sextos de ambos lados
tendremos que se es igual a 65 un sexto
así que ya tenemos todo listo para poder
resolver este problema de hecho ya
tenemos nuestra fórmula verdad porque la
fórmula sabíamos que tenía que ser una
cúbica de este estilo y ya sabemos quién
es a b y c así que la aquí tendríamos
que en realidad nuestra fórmula es un
tercio por n al cubo
un medio por n cuadrada más un sexto por
n y voy a parar el vídeo aquí
con esto ya hemos terminado si quieres
tú ahora por ejemplo calcular la suma de
los cuadrados de 1 a 100 ya no es
necesario elevar cada uno al cuadrado y
después sumarlos no simplemente ya
podemos
calcular esa suma con esta fórmula de
aquí